[Music]
alright guys well we were just saying
had you told us two years ago the three
of you had me sitting down happy to be
together we would not have believed you
believe us because last year when we
talked you told me you had PTSD
post-traumatic stasi disorder everybody
seems more mature than ever this season
especially Kristen thank you do you
think everybody's grown up excluded I
think you know what I'm so proud of our
group of friends because I just think
that if you can overcome some really
dark dark things you only turn out to be
better friends after that and I feel
like we have this like wolf pack
mentality now we won't let anyone hurt
each other only we can bring each other
you don't give up about anyone but
yourself a lot of people feel that
you're fake a lot so why are you friends
with me if I'm fake yeah you guys have
overcome a lot of things that a lot of
friend groups do not survive what makes
your group survive those things having
history people always like so they're
like but you do like the worst things to
each other you you screw each other over
in the most extreme ways like how like
how do you I don't really have a clear
answer for that but I think it just
speaks volumes of how much we do value
and really do care for each other you've
been throwing rocks well because I call
you like a [ __ ] this season it's very
much in my mind old guard vs. Lala and
James
Justin's twosome does that change it all
this season yeah okay what can we tease
that you have a lot to look forward to
yeah well we be surprised by any kind of
chefs yeah shifts in the group and I
think people that watch the show from
the beginning will
okay does everyone survive the season
make it to the end well I mean we're
still alive well all I had T's that she
liked left the show it's what she said
survival Darwinism at its finest
how to survive and if I'm rules all
right
yeah the three of you it's so easy why
don't you learn when are people gonna
learn
[Music]